[Music]
it's off the record [ __ ] I know no cuz
it just squeak it's like well the second
round of that I'm just gonna do a new
[ __ ] yeah mixed next week it might be
this do you think it's aren't you doing
that oh you're giving it away
Oh record see you give it them all on it
away hey I'm not gonna tune it anymore
when I bring out new instruments like
this mmm I like how that's an instrument
okay can't wait hit album to drop oh
this one's this one's the best yeah
anytime there's a sad story
i'ma pull this [ __ ] out now because I
don't want things to get too dark
anymore yeah yeah a man murdered his
daughter like oh it's sad but then
alright it's cool yeah yeah but but the
cops caught him oh they're saving the
day they just need a breather all like
those mass shootings and you just on a
building are wait what do you really
mean honestly I don't think I can dig
myself out of the hole that I just
created
what do you really I was just trying to
say that that's a lovely instrument and
whoever invented it did a great job
allotted society and humanity and Jo
does a great job of utilizing it like
r2d2 although yeah it is art it's like
um Danka
yeah I used to be able to do that hard
to do - like a week ago but can you
bring that when we go to Vegas mm-hmm
and then everywhere we go we're gonna
look at that we're allowed to bring it
to the tables or if the dealers are like
sir like you know how it's like all
people get you know how superstitious
they're yeah there are there's already
people that are like [ __ ] playing
craps holding their ear and doing she
like that they're gonna hear that noise
and they keep losing seat right gonna be
so [ __ ] pissed I'll bust out this one
it's concealable oh my gosh so last
night Casey and I helped Isaac finish
his fourth grade project and it was the
first time he had to build an actual
model no cause it do you remember like
back and forth or at least one I
remember when I was in fourth grade it
would be about missions and stuff and
now Isaac or apparel Sarah Knipper Oh
Sarah
who's the [ __ ] Padre that's
established all these missions should
know cuz you're from the area where they
all started yeah oh so interesting it
wasn't a nerd what he landed buddy
that's missing a [ __ ] patch of hair
it was interesting at my oh this is an
agency [ __ ] I better learn about
I remember any of that stuff anyway so
write the word of God
yeah so then I was able to pick at him
like a lot of topics and so he picked
early Hollywood and so he decided that
he wants to he wanted to create the
Hollywood Hills where the Hollywood sign
is yeah and we were all the Coquette
celebrities are did he put them all in
the back of it Harvey Weinstein talking
to a girl like Oh some Instagram models
in a bikini like in front of the
Hollywood sign taking a selfie mm-hmm
you know it's funny were talking about
it because for the entire project I was
kind of like the party pooper like
trying to be really strict on the time
because we didn't have a lot of time to
work on the project like the producer so
then I could have saying that and then
Isaac was like who are any famous
producers and really we can't think of
anyone other than Jerry Bruckheimer
judge on out the town Oh true but yeah I
mean that's the only one and then so
Casey and I were like even Steven
Spielberg they've all produced - yeah
that's true even Adam Sandler yeah actor
producers so you guys failed it's what
the room but then he was like why why
are you cuz he saw us hesitating when
were and laughing when we said how
everybody see me is like why like what's
so funny we're like Oh cuz he's not a
very good guy
yeah how do you how do you tell a I tell
up yeah like exactly what happened he
was he harassed the ladies he made the
best movies but he grabbed some titties
so is this a like V project of fourth
grade that's what you call it the fourth
grade project I never did [ __ ] like that
my parents couldn't help me with [ __ ]
dang there were a lot of like shitty
home kids that I went to school with
wouldn't help us with our projects or
anything so like it wasn't that abnormal
like almost half of us didn't door
assignments the only like a few of those
like science fairs and [ __ ] were like
people are bringing in the project and
half of us didn't do it
I did bring it in with like a nerd yeah
I mean I always thought it was dope and
I was like man that's really cool I want
to know how to do that but I thought
that they were genius obviously is their
parents helping them yeah our school
like we all had to do the same thing so
like we got the instructions and
everything and
like everyone did the exact same thing
and we had to build a topographical map
of California Wow bread dough in fourth
grade yeah
you will earn my typed up a typography
typography yeah so we like that's the
difference between school districts yeah
good school district it's like down it's
a shitty one you're like I don't know
these boards and like you had to there
was a recipe for the dough that we had
to make so we had to make the dough at
home bring it in and like we all made it
together at school and that dough like
hardens you have to like make the
mountains and like all the whatever then
hardens and then you painted it the
colors of like like the sea level and
then like the elevation like pretty
[ __ ] it fits tight
yeah dude I thought it was advanced when
I made one of my school project it's the
paper and I made it look like a scroll
that is cool
yeah and animate it like the scroll but
then I thought I was dope because I
would just soak the paper in coffee
yeah and that was like fall cows [ __ ] I
think I think that is that's smart you
know what I did I got paper enough I
wrinkled it up 20 times they just threw
dirt and just burned my paper yeah I
worry about this damn different kids
have different take me did you ever have
to like build baskets or do gold digging
or anything like that I'm still digging
I remember they had us like yeah yeah
gold not very fun yeah cuz that's all
good no that's what we wear grade stuff
yeah I don't remember or at least I
don't know if he has anything like that
planned out for the year but it was so
cool do it as you find goal it's like
pyrite and it's the goal did you guys
ever have to work on a pirate ship what
I think for fourth or fifth grade field
trip you went on a pirate ship that
would have been my dream first of all I
have to that's what they they agreed it
they greeted you and then there's this
pirate ship I don't know it's parked
like on the beach somewhere and then
but they would be they're super into
character darling I gotta do all these
things and then I so every kid would be
assigned a different mission once doing
a sale ones catching fish ones doing
whatever and then halfway through that
and then they kept telling us if we
didn't behave that they would leave us
out in the ocean that is far you I think
I was fourth grade I was nine and then I
I realized they probably just told you
no they're telling all the kids and then
I realized halfway through the day we
never even left the dock sale somewhere
and we just [ __ ] stuck there it's
probably like Queen Mary where you can't
even leave ya know just there the whole
time and I realize how stable the boat
was which means it's probably just
attached to the docks
so it doesn't even have the natural like
rock yes yeah but I never saw whales
ever I've been like three times never
saw will I remember that [ __ ] we saw
dolphins yeah and then we got yelled at
by the guys at the jail cell I remember
what we're taught at school did you go
my parents never helped me with this
budget cuts okay the [ __ ] school
buses were also the ones where they
transfer to Michael all the students
were on about that it is a chain that
connects all of them but it was like a
straight jail on the harbor and then all
the kids were like on the boat watching
and then like all the inmates were at
the at the fence letting like cussing at
Alcatraz were weren't you
oh Terminal Island like close to San
Pedro yeah yeah okay we went out on
harbor and then when we are coming back
like all the kids were like watching the
inmates just yell be like you want this
booking like ah [ __ ] you and then all
the kids were just like and it'll like
you you what the [ __ ] you would wear
those pants I'm making my [ __ ] and it
were all just like it's like a boat full
of kids just rolling by and then all the
teachers are just like probably like
yeah
and then we're all like what the [ __ ]
they probably did that on purpose you
guys are a bunch of ass what a horrid
whale-watching we got yellow but
everyone's wearing like a parka would
like the fur around it but here Johnny
here's some binoculars he puts it on it
oh you thought they said whale watching
they say jail whale watching
what kind of filters dude in Texas I
don't know nothing as cool as that we
don't have we didn't have a notion to go
to learn about no missionaries
there's no missionary you have like a
fourth-grade Texas project yeah cuz
teca's fourth grades where you learn
about your state so like have it
remember great I remember we got
assigned an SF 8 yeah oh yeah I got
Laura de and I'd be like a whole thing
on Florida how do you guys remember this
[ __ ] oh the only thing I remember I
remember fourth grade because it was all
in California I remember making a tissue
bomb thing we made a tissue box like a
container thing where you know how like
you could put stuff yeah I could like a
cover oh you're like for art class
what's my cover you get a design or a
tissue box yeah it's like it's like you
could put this inside of it that was in
high school high school in my if my in
my us in my US history class right one
of the project that's been that we
worked on for at least two weeks was a
[ __ ] map of the US and we were
coloring the different states and
writing the different capitals of each
state and people were getting that [ __ ]
wrong that was fifth grade
yeah but people were getting that [ __ ]
wrong oh my god
I was like wow what the [ __ ] okay but
this is pretty easy yeah that's tight so
you don't have any Texas like projects
or like Texas I'm sure we did I just
don't remember remember any field trip
we were in Dallas so we weren't even
close to any of the historical stuff so
I don't know well I remember you said
you would take a ski trip but I was like
in high school though and that wasn't
like for educational purposes that was
like our end-of-the-year Orchestra or
like whatever groups thing look you were
in band at high school orchestra oh it's
not the same did you know that oh that's
why you know how to [ __ ] hit it
yeah I was like damn Casey you are fast
I never hit in the same direction though
oh yeah good last week movement we go
play tennis it was Joe Casey David Jess
and me
so like the five of us we all went and
just kept trying to teach me how to play
tennis and until this day my arm is down
oh yeah still sore how you're alive is
America it still that was a week ago
no it was like four days ago she got
babies okay it wasn't a week ago you
have to exercise this muscle why do cuz
I realize I've never used this and I
also really Nicki pretty okay my wrist
is really weak as soon as the ball would
hit it the wrecking of the Lake Dam
I'm surprised you don't get sore by
[ __ ] eating and you lifted a fork
it's not far off my dog gets sore all
the time very some kelp I don't like to
eat [ __ ] I'll give you some coconut
water because you need some potassium
[ __ ] you need some salt like collagen
powder thing for like my joints and I
feel like imma bite well those [ __ ]
grip things too damn girl exercise
something I'll just put up that you know
that I think it's at least that you can
just sit there and
yeah I know I gotta get my body right
now especially we're trying to have kids
in the future I want to have a nice
vessel home for the future kids and pass
on your good genes yeah well I don't
know I think every Friday now we're
doing this thing with David where we
just walk three miles and play tennis or
box or whatever at the park and it's
been pretty yeah it's pretty even I've
been trying to get 10,000 steps a day
and it's hard like many are you got
usually we'd get 10,000 steps but it's
like since we work at home we live at
home you don't even like really need to
go anywhere unless I have an audition or
he is like a writing thing so you know
you're just at home and like you don't
realize how little you walk like because
you're supposed to get 10,000 steps a
day but you should do a countdown
celebration like 9,998 it's more like
we're on the treadmill it's like I can't
spend an hour already and we're just
like both of us are more like finally
because I think my steps are here and
know by the time it gets a 10,000 you're
just like okay fine thank you cars
faster than a wheelchair come join us on
Fridays oh yeah yeah it's fun we got to
make it fun I think everything has to be
enjoyable or else you're gonna burn out
and be like I hate this yeah well it was
enjoyable when we could walk outside but
then it was raining oh so then it was we
had it on the treadmill and then I hate
the treadmill I like running outside I
run like five miles every other day but
like the days off like we have to get it
somewhere and we had to do it all on
treadmill cause it was all raining
outside do you hate the treadmill more
than rain I only because which is fun
but I get colds like cuz you're running
in the wind I like that feeling I'm a
cold person because I get warm while I'm
running so then the water starts feeling
good and when we went it was sprinkling
and I was like honest feels really nice
um later on that night we do jacuzzi it
was raining that's cool
was really cold but sound like being in
a nice warm - I like that we're just in
the water toward neck like this it was
like the downtown buildings that's cool
yeah so come join us
I like in Hawaii when it's like warm
rain oh yeah that was like at they're
waiting yeah we were in the pool and
we're like oh yeah they just started
pouring on us we were playing basketball
in the rain I'm surprised none of us got
injured yeah we were drenched like a
[ __ ]
speaking of trips man I'm pretty excited
about Vegas Vegas I'm super craps and
we're gonna win so much money money is
so exciting
yeah even if I win like 50 bucks I've
like hate it when I win money [ __ ] my
way I want to lose I want to go home
broken I'm like yes the loss of money
because you're just like I gambled like
I went all-in I'm gonna balls to the
wall because I feel like when you gamble
and you come up that means you play it
safe you didn't make any mistakes that's
not true you could have risked it all on
like you you come up like so you come up
right and then you had another
opportunity - right after to lose it and
you decided not to so that means you
lose every time you go home cuz you just
go I won so big I'm gonna put it all
well there's times I go home where I win
and there's times I go home where I lose
and I always find myself feeling way
happier when I go home losing that's the
sign of a gambling addict you know that
people are addicted to losing that's why
what's that yeah yeah like if your
gambling addict you're addicted you
agree that you're [ __ ] addicted we're
not going to Vegas you're not pulling
because you're not satisfied you're
never satisfied with what you win yeah
you're not satisfied because but until
you lose I'm still blaming on your
childhood what are you you're [ __ ] up
to the head oh yeah yeah a hundred
percent snowboards well yeah a hundred
percent but I like that Vegas is the one
place that you could go on vacation and
come back with money with more money
than when you went there everyone else
you go on vacation you you're spending a
bunch of money losing more money yeah
that's your buyer but the cool thing is
like the whole cop system and everything
yeah that's genius 3 they [ __ ] get
you guys even though you lose money it's
like you didn't pay for anything yeah
so you feel good about it that's like
Vegas I actually got a three night stay
at a a Tijeras that's cool it's an
Indian Reservation it's not the Vegas no
but this one's really dope cuz I went
there with Kevin and Bri and there's
like waterfalls and all this [ __ ] and
it's a long one that's cool it's like
yeah and then the waters warm so you
used to have the dopest pools in Vegas
like on the strip and then they just
changed them all to being like squares
like rectangles yeah because I think
they just use them more for parties now
to like have parties instead of one of
them you go through where iam what I
don't know if it's golden nugget or
Mandalay Bay or whatever golden nugget
Oh downtown yeah so you go through the
water slide and then the water slide
there's like char describes you can see
the Mandalay Bay the same because I know
they have a shark thing I don't know I'm
one of those do it you they rebuilt it
Mandalay Bay they they just have a pool
like a just a rectangle pool they have
parties there but they might have a
separate thing with an aquarium you have
this the pool area is like yeah the
beach think would that gives you fake
waves yeah and then they have an actual
aquarium but it's so shallow it's just
like I think feel like so gross when
there's tons of people and it's shallow
and it's just like
it just feels like everyone's body is
what's making it well I'm definitely
peeing in that water we need way more
water to dilute that beep beep are you
looking at swim at the same Falls
well yeah it used to be cool for
swimming like when you were a kid or I
don't know if you ever went there as a
kid but you can't gamble when your kids
hang out the pools and it used to be
tight like there used to be lazy rivers
and like wave pools and so much stuff
and then they just redid all of them to
be more of a party zone so I feel like
it's more fun they make more money that
way yeah exactly
bunch of people come to a club night
club whatever Cabana or whatever yep
yeah because otherwise you're just
utilizing your pool for the guests which
they don't pay anything they just go and
I just feel like Vegas like he's you
saying it just became super posh because
before it was like this really cool like
adult Disneyland yeah I went to New York
New York and now you're like on the East
Coast Paris and it was family-friendly
not anymore
that's the thing yes that's the Vegas I
love like 90s where arcades there was
like there was so much [ __ ] for kids to
do torn cards they could pick up from
the floor they clean up that they clean
that up though because I remember when I
was a kid I went there it was like
sprawled all over the floor now you
barely see them in the corner of the
sidewalk those kids don't even get to
see a new day a minute way more posh now
and kids don't really have that much to
do anymore either
that's so sad there used to be such a
family place well fact it's so weird
it's like a family place with hookers
and coke like the coca-cola factor yeah
I never got to go I wanted to go yeah it
was so - yeah again you get like a
sample true yeah like well there was I
heard that they closed it they did they
closed it like ten years ago but like it
was tight because you go in this first
of all you enter through a coke bottle
like a giant glass coke bottle you go up
in the elevator and then you're it's
like a whole tour and like you go
through it and there's this one part
where that shoots a coca-cola across the
room into your cup
yeah and then then there's another room
with the sample room where you can taste
coca-cola from all around the world and
there's all these different flavors and
like weird like watermelon coke like
things that you never gonna do that
anymore okay nah
[ __ ] [ __ ] no you learn the history
of everything and then like you're polar
bears bear I'm switching a Pepsi photo
op I want to learn the history of
everything yeah it was cool I saw a
Pepsi documentary the other day how was
that pretty interesting but that's about
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]